The Sovereign Grant comes from the crown
estate a vast and diverse 16 billion
pound portfolio of property including
London's West End and Regent Street and
land portfolios agricultural Coastal and
most of the seabed it belongs to the
reigning monarch but all of the revenue
goes to the treasury which gives a
percentage back to the palace and that's
the Sovereign Grant it's currently just
over 86 million pounds now although the
London property portfolio has taken a
hit dropping by half a billion pounds
the crown estate generated profits of
442 million pounds now this increase was
largely driven by six offshore Wind Farm
licenses which increased Revenue by more
than half a billion pounds now we're all
facing the pressure of rising costs and
so too are the royal family although the
sovereign months is 86.3 million they
spent more
107.5 million which means they've had to
dip into their reserves where's the
money going well here are some of the
costs payroll like many businesses their
labor costs are up nearly three and a
half million pounds Rising energy bills
to their gas bill went up almost a
million pounds and big events last year
like the Platinum Jubilee and the
Queen's funeral that much higher
Hospitality costs Rising by over a
million pounds all of these extra costs
mean Palace reserves have dropped over
22 million now these are still huge sums
of money and that's of course before you
add in the cost of security which isn't
covered by The Sovereign Grant or the
incomes from the duchies of Lancaster
and Cornwall and as ever the big
challenge for the royal family showing
and proving their public service is
worth the cost